Ghostbusters Frozen Empire isn't just
another addition to the Ghostbusters
franchise it's a complete rework of the
mythology a continuation of where
afterlife left off and an emotionally
complex story dealing with themes like
loss betrayal and resentment here's
everything I could dig up Ghostbusters
Frozen Empire plans on picking up where
Ghostbusters afterlife left off when
egon's grandchildren and the rest of the
Ghostbusters defeated goer the reason
why after life is getting its own sequel
is because of how much both critics and
fans truly loved it it had a ton of
heart that hasn't been seen in the
previous Ghostbusters sequels it really
wasn't until Jason wrightman stepped in
as director and told a deeply emotional
story that also served as a tribute to
Harold RIS Frozen Empire will also be
bringing the franchise back to its
original New York City Roots the
Spangler family is returning to the New
York City Firehouse to team up with the
original Ghostbusters the film is also
said in the summer ironically but when
the discovery of a powerful ancient
artifact unleashes a mysterious evil
force the Ghostbusters have to come
together to save their home and the
world from a lethal second Ice Age
although Jason wman stepped down as
director for Frozen Empire he's still
heavily involved as a co-writer and
producer he did manage to reveal to fans
that there's a high probability we're
going to see a lot of familiar faces
from the Ghostbusters past quote there
is a lot of time and opportunity for vgo
the Carpathian to make his return look
are you saying that's the only painting
of vgo the Carpathian maybe he's riding
a horse in another one maybe impaling
someone in another one naturally it
makes sense they'll be bringing back
characters from the franchise because in
Ghostbusters after life we did get to
see The Return of goer and her evil
minions I'll be getting more into what
that means for the future here in a
minute the entire cast of Ghostbusters
afterlife is going to be returning to
Frozen Empire most notably the Spangler
family Mckenna Grace as egon's
granddaughter Kenna Grace is a
spectacular actress and she's basically
going to be our new CEO Finn wolfart as
his grandson and Carrie as his
daughter it's also been confirmed we're
going to be seeing Paul Rudd then we
have of course Paul Rudd a master
comedian probably Logan Kim Celeste
o'conor Bill Murray and Danny pots among
many others who have had previous roles
in the franchise the only person we're
going to be missing from the previous
cast is Sigourney Weaver but we are
getting some fresh faces on the screen
like Patton Oswald James acter and Emily
Allen lint something we can expect from
Frozen Empire is a change in the
emotional Stakes basically the plot is
going to be driven by some powerful
emotions and difficult themes the
characters are battling with things like
betrayal loss and forgiveness Dan akroy
who plays the iconic role of Reay
revealed a little bit about how his
character is going through one of the
most challenging periods of his life
even to the point of describing him as
resentful you know things have passed
him by Ghostbuster in this one you know
because they he's no longer licensed it
makes sense though as Ry has been
through so much throughout the decades
it's a completely different world for
him compared to where he was in 1984 and
speaking of different worlds we're
getting a whole new Narrative of
Mythology the Ghostbusters franchise has
never seen before it's been confirmed
that this Frozen Empire world is in a
post Garian era which opens up a ton of
space to create something new for the
characters to face director Gil Keenan
opened up about his new direction for
the film in an interview with Empire
magazine quote there are all new and
terrifying Stakes with fresh visual
references to draw on does anyone have
any theories on some of the things we
might be seeing what I do know is that
they wanted to close out the goer
chapter with the Spangler family leading
the narrative in afterlife but now with
both the new and old Generations coming
together they are able to take a
completely different direction that
audiences have never never seen before
because we are in a post Garian era that
means the Ghostbusters are going to have
to face a whole new big bad in the
film's poster recently released by Sony
you can see New York City is being
threatened by what looks like an army of
Frozen spirits that put the city at risk
of being frozen over what has been
confirmed is that the new villain is
called death chill which has the power
to end life through fear alone and frees
everything that steps into its path so
with the end of one major event comes
the birth of a brand new one and it
looks like the Ghostbusters are going to
have their hands full when it comes to
containing their own fear and keeping
calm when everything around them is
turning to ice with brand new mythology
driving the story familiar faces feeding
our insatiable Nostalgia a plot that
could take us in any direction a brand
new villain and terrifying emotional
Stakes driving this new film
Ghostbusters Frozen Empire isn't like
anything we've seen before in the
franchise what are you most excited to
see